nous vous l'annoncions dès hier annie
espagnol une hache et la ministre chargé
de l'industrie était en déplacement
aujourd'hui en touraine elle s'est
rendue dans deux entreprises
pharmaceutiques mobilisé pour la
production de vaccins arn messagers
récifs armes et fareva la ministre est
venu annoncer une bonne nouvelle une
aide de 35 millions d'euros pour le site
de mon compte rendu de cette visite
ministérielle avec paul boyer et lucas
chopin c'est une journée vaccin pour
agnès pannier rue nash et la ministre
chargé de l'industrie a passé la journée
en indre et loire
au programme ce matin une visite du site
de recife armes
hamon qui produit les futurs vaccins
moderna depuis presque deux semaines
pour la ministre cette production sur le
territoire français représente une
garantie d'autonomie dans la livraison
de doses de vaccins un objectif c'est
que le maximum des lignes de production
soit européenne de manière à assurer une
indépendance de production par rapport à
des chaînes de production mondiale
ces doses elles sont prises en charge
par modern à la sortie de l'usiné elles
sont ensuite dispatchés sur l'ensemble
de l'union européenne
ah bon l'entreprise suédoise récit
pharma réalisé près d'une centaine
d'embauchés depuis la pandémie
le site compte désormais 260 salariés
l'état lui a d'ores et déjà investi 35
millions d'euros dans récifs armes
de quoi encore augmenter la production
il s'agit d'un projet défunt ont lâché
un autre bâtiment et avec deux lignes de
production une ligne de des flacons et
une ligne avec des seringues préremplies
qui va faire presque doubler la capacité
chez nous agnès pannier rue nachi a
poursuivi par une visite du centre de
vaccination de saint-avertin avant de se
rendre à pocé sur cisse sur le site de
l'entreprise fareva l'entreprise par eva
travaillent sur la production du futur
vaccin allemand curve ac ce vaccin
pourrait être homologué en france à
partir de juin curve un café le choix de
fareva pour cette opération pour
démarrer son vaccin
donc c'est le premier site qui démarrera
pour la fabrication du vaccin curve axe
est un arn messagers en tout en 2021 ce
sont 250 millions de doses de vaccins
qui devraient être produites en france
les premières doses de moderne à
sortiront de l'usiné
demont à la mi mai